- Maligayang pagbabalik sa Understanding Quantum Information and Computation.
Ang pangalan ko ay John Watrous at ako ang Technical Director para sa
Education sa IBM Quantum.
Ito ang ikapitong aralin ng serye at sa araling ito tatalakayin natin ang phase estimation problem at kung paano natin ito malulutas
gamit ang quantum computer.
Pagkatapos ay ilalapat natin ang phase estimation sa problema ng integer factorization, na tinalakay natin sa nakaraang aralin.
Ang makukuha natin ay ang Shor's algorithm, na nagpapahintulot sa mga integer na ma-factorize sa polynomial na gastos o sa polynomial na oras kung gusto nating
isipin ito sa mga tuntunin ng oras na kinakailangan kaysa sa bilang ng
mga elementary na operasyon na kailangan natin.
Ito ang pinakamahalagang bahagi ng
mga quantum algorithm sa isang banda, at habang ang pag-factorize ng malalaking integer
ay maaaring may limitadong pakinabang para sa karamihan ng tao, nananatili itong isa sa pinaka-
nakakaengganyong ebidensya na mayroon tayo para sa hipotesis na ang mga quantum computer ay mag-aalok ng kapansin-pansing mga kalamangan
laban sa mga klasikal na computer. Narito ang isang pangkalahatang-ideya ng aralin.
Magsisimula tayo sa isang kahulugan ng phase estimation problem mismo, at pagkatapos ay tatalakayin natin ang isang paraan para malutas ang problemang ito
gamit ang quantum computer.
Gagawin natin ito nang isa-isa, simula sa kung ano ang maaari mong
isipin bilang isang uri ng pag-init.
Sa phase estimation problem, ang layunin ay mag-approximate ng
isang tiyak na tunay na numero at sa bahaging ito ng pag-init
makikita natin kung paano tayo makakakuha ng
napakababang katumpakan na
approximation sa numerong ito.
Hindi ito magiging
sapat para sa factoring kapag inilapat natin ang ating solusyon sa
phase estimation problem sa integer factorization,
kailangan natin ng medyo mataas na katumpakan na approximation, ngunit kapaki-pakinabang pa rin na magsimula sa ganitong uri ng pag-init
para lang makuha ang pakiramdam kung
paano gumagana ang buong bagay.
Pagkatapos ay tatalakayin natin ang isyu ng kung paano tayo makakakuha ng mas maraming katumpakan, at ito ay natural na
hahantong sa isang operasyon na kilala bilang Quantum Fourier transform.
Makikita natin kung ano mismo ang operasyong ito at kung paano ito maisasagawa
gamit ang isang quantum circuit.
At kapag mayroon na tayo nito, magagawa nating ilapat
ito sa phase estimation para makabuo ng isang pangkalahatang pamamaraan para malutas ang problema
na may napakataas na katumpakan.
Pagkatapos sa huling bahagi ng aralin, makikita natin kung paano ang isang solusyon sa
phase estimation problem ay nagpapahintulot sa atin na mag-factor ng mga integer nang mahusay.
At partikular na ang makukuha natin ay ang Shor's algorithm para sa
integer factorization, o kahit man lang isang bagay na katumbas ng Shor's algorithm.
Ang paraan ng pagtatrabaho nito ay nagbibigay tayo sa ating sarili ng isang stepping stone, na isa pang problema na tinatawag na order finding problem.
At partikular na makikita natin kung paano natin malulutas ang order finding problem gamit ang phase estimation procedure at pagkatapos ay makikita natin kung paano
tayo maka-factor ng mga integer
sa pamamagitan ng paglutas ng order finding problem. Magsisimula tayo sa isang espesyal na kaso ng isang teorema na tinatawag na Spectral theorem,
at partikular na itutuon natin ang ating pansin sa kung ano ang sinasabi ng teorema
sa atin para sa mga unitary matrix.
Ang spectral theorem ay isang napakahalagang teorema mula sa linear algebra at
functional analysis.
Sinasabi nito sa atin ng isang kawili-wiling bagay tungkol sa kung paano maaaring ipahayag ang ilang mga linear na pagmamapa sa isang tiyak na anyo, na madalas na tinatawag na
spectral decomposition,
na kapaki-pakinabang para sa maraming dahilan.
At tulad ng sinabi ko, itutuon natin ang ating pansin sa kung ano ang sinasabi ng teoremang ito
sa atin para sa mga unitary matrix.
Ang spectral theorem ay
mas pangkalahatan kaysa dito. Hindi ito gumagana para sa lahat ng matrix, ngunit gumagana ito para sa isang klase ng mga matrix
na tinatawag na mga normal na matrix, na kinabibilangan ng lahat ng unitary matrix pati na rin ang ilang mga matrix
na hindi unitary.
Ngunit para lang panatilihing simple ang mga bagay, ilalimit natin ang ating pansin
sa mga unitary matrix sa ngayon dahil iyon lang ang kailangan natin para sa
mga layunin ng araling ito.
Narito ang isang pahayag ng spectral theorem para lamang sa mga unitary matrix.
Ipagpalagay na ang U ay isang
N by N unitary matrix.
Ang sinasabi ng teorema
ay dapat na mayroon talagang isang orthonormal na batayan ng
mga vector, psi one hanggang psi N,
kasama ang N complex na numero
Lambda one hanggang Lambda N, lahat ay nasa complex unit circle upang ang U ay maaaring ipahayag
tulad ng mayroon tayo sa ekwasyong ito.
Ito ay tinatawag na isang spectral
decomposition ng U, tulad ng nabanggit ko na, at maaari itong maging napaka-maginhawa upang malaman na ang U ay maaaring isulat sa ganitong paraan.
Maaari itong maging maginhawa minsan na magkaroon ng mga vector na ito at mga numerong ito kapag nagtatrabaho tayo sa
isang partikular na unitary matrix U, at maaari rin itong maging napaka-
kapaki-pakinabang na malaman lamang
na ang ganitong uri ng expression ay palaging posible bilang isang paraan ng pagpapatunay ng ilang mga bagay tungkol sa mga unitary matrix halimbawa.
Sa pahayag ng teoremang ito, bawat isa sa mga numerong ito,
Lambda one hanggang lambda N, ay nakasulat sa isang partikular na paraan
bilang E sa kapangyarihang dalawang pi I times theta kung saan ang bawat isa sa mga theta
theta one hanggang theta N ay isang tunay na numero, at
babalikan natin ang paraang ito
ng pagsusulat ng bawat isa sa mga
numerong ito sa sandali.
Isang mahalagang bagay na dapat pansinin
tungkol sa mga vector at numerong ito ay na ang bawat vector psi
K ay dapat na isang eigenvector ng matrix U na may
kaukulang eigenvalue na lambda K.
Na nangangahulugang kung
paramin natin ang psi K ng U, ang makukuha natin ay lambda K times psi K.
Kaya ang ginagawa ng U sa bawat isa sa mga vector na ito ay ang pag-multiply lamang nito ng kaukulang numero na lambda K.
Sa pangkalahatan para sa ilang arbitrary na vector, hindi ganito ang paraan ng pagtatrabaho ng U, ngunit ang mga eigenvector ay espesyal.
At ang sinasabi ng teorema sa atin ay na mayroon talagang
isang ortho normal na batayan ng mga eigenvector na ito.
Ang ekwasyong ito sa ibaba sa pamamagitan ng paraan, ay sumusunod mula sa expression na mayroon tayo para sa U mula sa teorema, kasama ang katotohanan na
ang mga vector ay orthonormal.
Kung i-multiply mo ang
expression ng U sa anumang psi K at gamitin ang orthonormality ng mga vector, makakakuha ka ng isang kabuuan kung saan
ang lahat ng mga termino ay zero
maliban sa isa sa kanila, at ang isang termino na natitira sa atin ay ganito ang hitsura.
Ngayon ay maaari na nating tukuyin ang
phase estimation problem.
Ang problema ay medyo
kakaiba tulad ng makikita natin.
Binibigyan tayo ng dalawang bagay. Una, binibigyan tayo ng paglalarawan ng isang unitary quantum circuit,
na kumikilos sa N qubit
para sa ilang pagpili ng N, at kapag sinabi natin na ito
ay isang unitary circuit,
ibig sabihin lang natin ay lahat ng
gate ay unitary, kaya walang mga sukat
sa circuit na ito.
Pangalawa, binibigyan tayo ng isang N qubit na estado na psi, at iyon ang kakaibang bahagi.
Mayroon talagang isang quantum
state input para sa problemang ito, at ito ay isang solong kopya ng estado.
Para sa lahat ng iba pang mga computational na problema na tinalakay natin sa seryeng ito, ang input ay klasikal, alinman sa anyo ng isang string
ng mga bit o bilang isang black box.
At hindi iyon nakakagulat dahil ang mga computational na problema na nakakaharap tayo sa ating pang-araw-araw na buhay ay malamang na klasikal,
dahil iyon ang mga
problemang pinaka-mahalaga sa atin.
Ang paraan na maaari mong
isipin ang problemang ito ay ito ay isang bagay na lumalabas o malamang na lalabas bilang isang sub problem.
At ang phase estimation procedure na sa kalaunan ay mabubuo natin ay isang bagay na
karaniwang ginagamit natin bilang isang sub-routine
sa loob ng ilang mas malaking computation, marahil isa para sa isang klasikal
na problema na mahalaga sa atin.
Ngayon, ito ay magiging isang promise problem at ang estado na psi ay hindi
basta-basta anumang quantum state.
Ipinangako sa atin na ang psi ay isang eigenvector ng anumang unitary na operasyon U na inilalarawan ng ibinigay na circuit.
At ang layunin ay hanapin o
i-approximate ang eigenvalue na tumutugma sa eigenvector na psi.
Hayaan nating isahaysay ang problema nang
medyo mas tumpak.
Ang input ay binubuo ng isang unitary
quantum circuit sa N qubit, na maaaring i-encode bilang isang string ng mga bit
gamit ang anumang paraan na gusto natin para sa pag-encode ng mga paglalarawan ng quantum circuit, kasama ang isang N qubit na estado na psi.
Maaari nating tawagan ang circuit sa anumang gusto natin, ngunit ang talagang mahalaga sa mga tuntunin ng pahayag ng problemang ito ay ang unitary na operasyon mismo
na isinasagawa kapag pinatakbo ang circuit, at ang unitary na operasyong iyon
ay inilarawan ng Matrix U.
Ngunit hindi tayo binibigyan ng U bilang isang matrix, binibigyan lamang tayo ng paglalarawan ng isang quantum circuit na nagpapatupad ng U.
Ang pangako, tulad ng nasabi ko na, ay na ang psi ay isang eigenvector ng U.
Kaya kung pinatakbo natin ang ating circuit sa psi, makukuha natin ang psi na lumalabas na pinarami ng anumang eigenvalue,
na magiging isang global
phase sa sitwasyong iyon.
At sa wakas, ang output ng problema ay isang approximation sa eigenvalue na tumutugma sa psi, at partikular na naghahanap tayo ng
isang approximation sa tunay na numero theta, sa pagitan ng zero at isa, kabilang ang
zero, ngunit hindi kabilang ang isa
na nakakatugon sa ekwasyon
na mayroon tayo sa screen.
Upang ipaliwanag ang paraang ito ng
pag-parameterize ng eigenvalue na tumutugma sa pis, at upang linawin din ang ibig sabihin natin ng approximation,
gumawa tayo ng larawan ng
complex unit circle.
Maaari tayong maglagay ng mga numero na isa, I,
negatibong isa, at negatibong I sa kanilang karaniwang mga lugar at maaari tayong isaalang-alang
ang ilang arbitrary na punto sa
bilog na na-parameterize ng theta tulad ng mayroon tayo sa pahayag ng problema.
Ito ang punto na
nakukuha natin kung magsisimula tayo sa isa at umiikot ng anggulo ng
dalawang beses na pi times theta, kaya ang anggulo ay hindi
theta, ito ay dalawang pi theta,
at isa pang paraan ng pag-iisip tungkol dito ay na kung magsisimula tayo sa isa at maglalakbay ng distansyang dalawang pi theta sa bilog mismo,
maaabot natin ang ating punto, E sa
dalawang beses na pi times theta.
Ang bawat punto sa complex unit circle ay maaaring katawanin sa ganitong paraan
para sa isang natatanging pagpili ng theta.
At iyon ay dahil pumupunta tayo
sa buong bilog habang ang theta ay mula zero hanggang isa, at kung pupunta tayo lahat
hanggang sa theta equals isa,
babalik tayo sa
simula sa theta equals zero, kaya iyon ang dahilan kung bakit kasama ang zero, ngunit hindi kasama ang isa.
Para lang matiyak na ang bawat
punto sa complex unit circle ay tumutugma sa isang natatanging halaga ng theta sa hanay na isinasaalang-alang natin.
Mayroong iba't ibang paraan
na maaari nating isipin ang pag-approximate ng isang partikular na halaga ng theta, ngunit ang paraan na gagawin natin ay ang pag-approximate ng theta gamit ang isang fraction,
kung saan ang denominator
ay dalawa sa kapangyarihang M para sa ilang pagpili ng positibong integer M, at ang numerator ay isang integer y
sa pagitan ng zero at dalawa sa M minus isa.
Maaari mong isipin ito bilang isang mbit approximation sa theta kung gusto mo, at maaari nating isulat ang numerong ito sa binary notation
kung saan mayroon tayong isang binary point na sinusundan ng binary
na representasyon ng Y.
Sinasabi ko binary point sa pamamagitan ng paraan
kaysa decimal point dahil ang decimal ay nangangahulugang base 10 at pinag-uusapan ko ang base two
dito, ngunit pareho ang ideya.
Ngunit sa anumang kaso maaari rin
nating isipin ito bilang isang fraction tulad ng
lumalabas sa screen.
At para maging malinaw, kapag nag-iisip tayo tungkol sa
mga approximation sa kontekstong ito, dapat na maunawaan
na ang mga halaga ng theta
malapit sa zero at ang mga halaga ng theta malapit sa isa ay talagang magkadugtong.
Halimbawa, kung ang theta ay katumbas ng 0.99 at ina-approximate natin ang halagang ito
ng theta ng halagang zero,
kung gayon iyon ay isang medyo magandang approximation sa kahulugan na ito ay
loob ng isa sa ating isang daan mula sa aktwal na halaga, kapag
nakabalot tayo sa bilog
at bumalik sa zero kapag dumating sa isa.
Ang terminong modular one ay minsan ginagamit upang ilarawan ang sitwasyon, kung saan tayo ay
katumbas ng theta equals isa sa theta equals zero.
Ang punto ay talagang pinagmamasdan natin ang lokasyon ng punto
E sa dalawang pi I theta sa unit circle,
at ang pag-iisip tungkol sa paraang ito
ng pag-approximate ng theta ay may katuturan kapag mayroon tayong layuning iyon sa isip.
Ang pahayag ng problema mismo,
tulad ng lumalabas sa screen, ay hindi tiyak tungkol sa kung gaano kaganda ang approximation sa theta na kailangang maging,
ngunit iyon ay isang bagay na maaari nating i-fine tune ayon sa ating mga pangangailangan.
Sa ilang mga sitwasyon maaari tayong maging nasisiyahan sa isang mababang katumpakan na
approximation sa theta, at sa ibang mga sitwasyon maaari tayong humingi ng
isang napakataas na katumpakan na approximation, at ang pahayag ng problema mismo
ay maaaring pinuhin nang naaayon.
Susunod ay makikita natin kung paano natin malulutas
ang phase estimation problem gamit ang isang quantum computer at
magsisimula tayo sa isang pag-init.
Hindi ito ang ating panghuling
solusyon sa problema.
Ang gagawin natin ay gamitin ang phase kickback phenomenon upang subukang matuto ng isang bagay
tungkol sa eigenvalue na tumutugma sa isang ibinigay na eigenvector.
Alalahanin na sa
phase estimation problem binibigyan tayo ng paglalarawan
ng isang unitary quantum circuit para sa ilang operasyon U,
at ang unang ginagawa natin ay
gamitin ang paglalarawang ito ng circuit upang lumikha ng isang bagong circuit na nagpapatupad ng isang controlled U na operasyon tulad ng
makikita sa screen.
Ito ay medyo simple gawin. Ang maaari nating gawin ay magdagdag ng isang control qubit, na makikita sa
itaas sa diagram na ito
at gamitin ang bagong control qubit na ito bilang isang control para sa bawat solong gate na
lumalabas sa ating circuit.
Kaya lahat ng gate ay inilalapat kung ang control qubit na ito ay itinakda sa isa, at wala sa kanila ang inilalapat kung ang control qubit ay itinakda sa zero,
Ibig sabihin nito ay kailangan natin ng controlled na bersyon ng bawat gate na
lumalabas sa circuit U, ngunit hindi natin kailangang isipin
ang tungkol sa mga bagong controlled na gate na ito
bilang mga solong gate kung ayaw natin. Maaari silang ipatupad
bilang mga maliliit na circuit na gawa sa mga gate mula sa anumang set ng gate
na pinili nating gamitin. At kapag mayroon na tayo ng isang
controlled na bersyon ng U, maaari nating isaalang-alang ang pagpapatakbo ng circuit na ito,
kung saan una nating ilagay ang control qubit sa isang superposition ng zero at isa, ilapat ang controlled U gate sa eigenvector na side na ibinigay sa atin,
at pagkatapos ay ilapat ang isang Hadamard gate
sa control at sukatin.
Makikita natin kung bakit may katuturan ang paggawa nito habang tinutuos natin ang pagsusuri, ngunit kahit bago pa natin makuha ang mga detalye, maaari na tayong agad na makakita ng pagkakatulad
sa algorithm ni Deutsch halimbawa, kung saan nag-a-apply tayo ng isang
pares ng mga Hadamard gate at sumusukat bilang isang paraan
ng epektibong pagsisiyasat
kung ano ang ginagawa ng ilang ibinigay
na operasyon dito.
Ito ay isang controlled unitary
kaysa sa isang query gate, ngunit may napaka-katulad na mga ideya na gumagana.
Kaya tingnan natin kung ano ang ginagawa ng circuit.
Ang paunang estado ay ang eigenvector psi, naka-tensor sa zero
na estado para sa control qubit,
ang pag-apply ng unang Hadamard gate ay nagbabago ng estado ng
nangungunang qubit sa isang plus na estado at maaari nating palawakin ang buong
estado tulad ng ipinapakita dito.
Pagkatapos ay ini-apply natin ang controlled U na operasyon at ang ginagawa nito ay ang pag-apply ng U sa psi kapag ang control qubit ay itinakda sa isa,
ngunit hindi kapag ito ay itinakda sa zero. Kaya makukuha natin ang estado na pi two
na nakasulat sa screen.
Maaari nating pasimplehin ang estado
gamit ang katotohanang ang psi ay isang eigenvector ng U na may eigenvalue na e sa dalawang pi I theta.
Kaya makukuha natin ang eigenvalue na iyon na pinarami sa pangalawang
termino, ngunit hindi sa una.
At maaari nating pasimplehin gamit ang bilinearity
ng tensor product.
Kaya ang mayroon tayo dito ay ang phase kickback phenomenon, ngunit sa pagkakataong ito ito ay nangyayari para sa ilang arbitrary na eigenvector psi ng ilang arbitrary na unitary na operasyon U,
kumpara sa isang not na operasyon na inilalapat sa isang minus
na estado nang mas tiyak.
Kaya iyon ang estado pagkatapos na mailapat ang controlled U na operasyon.
Sa pamamagitan ng paraan, sulit
na maglaan ng isang sandali upang mapansin na ang estado ng ibabang dulo N qubit ay ang eigenvector pa rin psi.
Na maganda dahil
nagbibigay iyon sa atin ng pagkakataon na gamitin ito muli kung pipiliin natin.
Pagkatapos ay isinasagawa ang pangalawang Hadamard gate at narito ang estado na nakukuha natin.
At hindi ko ipinakita ang lahat ng
mga detalye ng derivasyon dito, ngunit kung i-apply mo ang
Hadamard gate at pasimplehin, ito ang dapat mong makuha.
Kaya iyon ang estado nang wala pang
sandali bago ang pagsukat.
Kaya maaari tayong tumuon sa estadong ito upang makita kung ano ang matututunan natin
tungkol sa theta sa pamamagitan ng pagsukat.
At kung susukat tayo ng nangungunang
qubit o ang pinaka-kanang qubit, ito ang mga probabilidad na makukuha natin para sa dalawang resulta.
At dito ginamit natin ang isang pares ng mga pangunahing formula na nag-uugnay ng mga sine at cosine
sa mga complex exponential upang ipahayag ang mga probabilidad na ito
sa mga tuntunin ng mga sine at cosine.
Partikular na, ang probabilidad na makakuha ng zero ay ang cosine squared ng pi times theta at ang probabilidad na makakuha ng isa
ay ang sin squared ng parehong anggulo. At ito ay may katuturan
dahil ang sin squared dagdag ang cosine squared ng
anumang anggulo ay katumbas ng isa.
Kaya ang ating mga probabilidad
ay nagkakabuuan sa isa tulad ng inaasahan natin.
At narito ang isang plot ng mga probabilidad na ito bilang isang function ng theta.
Para maging malinaw, ito ay isang plot ng
mga probabilidad mismo kumpara sa isang plot na nagpapakita ng isang solong probability distribution halimbawa.
Halimbawa, kung ang theta
ay katumbas ng kalahati, kung gayon ang probabilidad na
makakuha tayo ng resulta na isa na iginuhit sa purple ay katumbas ng isa
habang ang probabilidad
na makakuha ng resulta na zero, na iginuhit sa asul, ay zero.
Sa kabilang banda, kung ang theta ay katumbas ng isang
kapat o tatlong kapat, kung gayon pareho ang bawat isa sa dalawang resulta ang malamang.
At siyempre para sa lahat ng pagpili ng theta, ang kabuuan ng mga probabilidad ay katumbas ng isa tulad ng napansin na natin.
Kaya hindi natin natututunan nang eksakto kung ano ang
theta mula sa pamamaraang ito, ngunit nagbibigay ito sa atin ng ilang
impormasyon tungkol sa theta.
At kung iisipin natin ang isang sitwasyon kung saan ipinangako sa atin
na ang theta ay katumbas ng zero o ang theta ay katumbas ng kalahati, sasabihin ng pamamaraang ito sa atin
nang eksakto kung alin sa dalawa
ang mga posibilidad ito.
Kaya iyon ay isang simpleng paraan na maaari nating gamitin ang phase kickback phenomenon upang matuto ng isang bagay tungkol sa eigenvalue.
Kaya paano tayo matuto ng higit pa
tungkol sa eigenvalue?
Well, ito ay isang sitwasyon kung saan maaari nating hayaan
ang kamangmangan na maging ating gabay.
Dahil talagang wala talagang
masyadong maraming bagay na magagawa natin.
Hindi natin alam halos anuman
tungkol sa eigenvector na sin, at hindi rin natin alam
masyadong maraming tungkol sa operasyong U.
Mayroon tayong isang circuit para sa U, ngunit para sa lahat ng alam natin ito ay isang
napakasamang, nakalilitong gulo na hindi natin magagawang maibigay
ang anumang kahulugan sa pamamagitan ng pagsusuri nito.
Ngunit ang isang natural na opsyon ay ang patakbuhin ang circuit nang maraming beses.
Partikular na, maaari nating subukan gawin nang eksakto ang parehong bagay na ginawa natin, maliban na sa halip na mag-apply ng isang solong controlled U na operasyon,
ini-apply natin ang operasyong iyon nang dalawang beses. O maaari nating ilapat ito ng anumang bilang ng beses, ngunit magsimula tayo sa dalawang beses
para lang makita kung ano ang mangyayari.
Well, napaka-simple talaga kung ano ang mangyayari. Sa pamamagitan ng pag-apply ng controlled
U na operasyon nang dalawang beses, epektibo lang nating
ini-square ang eigenvalue
dahil mati-kick ito sa
phase ng nangungunang qubit nang dalawang beses kaysa sa isang beses lamang.
At kaya kapag nag-iisip tayo tungkol sa
mga probabilidad ng resulta bilang isang function ng theta, tayo ay karaniwang
dino-double ang frequency.
Para sa bawat posibleng pagpili ng theta, ang mga probabilidad ng resulta
ay pareho tulad ng magiging sila kung dino-double natin ang theta at pagkatapos
kinukuha ang fractional na bahagi
upang makakuha ng isang numero sa pagitan ng zero at isa.
Halimbawa, kung ang theta
ay katumbas ng kalahati, kung gayon ang eigenvalue ay negatibong isa.
Kaya sa pamamagitan ng pag-apply ng U nang dalawang beses epektibo nating ini-square ang eigenvalue at ang resulta ay pareho tulad ng magiging ito para sa theta equals zero.
Na ang probabilidad
para sa resulta na zero, nakalarawan sa asul, ay katumbas ng isa, at ang probabilidad para sa resulta na isa, nakalarawan sa purple, ay katumbas ng zero.
Ito ay napaka-simple, ngunit maaari tayong talagang makakuha ng
ilang karagdagang impormasyon tungkol sa theta sa pamamagitan ng paggawa nito.
Halimbawa, kung alam natin nang maaga na ang theta ay katumbas ng zero o ang theta equals isang kapat, kung gayon ihahayag ng circuit na ito sa atin
kung alin sa dalawa ang mga posibilidad.
Sa kabilang banda, hindi na natin mawaring mapagkilala ang kaso na ang theta ay katumbas ng zero mula sa kaso na ang theta equals kalahati.
Kaya ang pamamaraang ito ay hindi mahigpit na mas mahusay kaysa sa una kapag
nagkaroon tayo ng isang solong control U gate ngunit sa pamamagitan ng pagpapatakbo rin ng circuit na ito
maaari tayong makakuha ng karagdagang impormasyon.
Hindi agad malinaw
kung paano ang karagdagang impormasyon na maaari nating makuha sa pamamagitan ng pag-ulit ng controlled U na operasyon nang maraming beses
ay maaaring ipagkasundo sa
impormasyon na nakukuha natin sa pamamagitan ng pagsasagawa nito nang isang beses lamang, at sa katunayan ay maraming
mga paraan na maaari tayong magpatuloy.
Halimbawa, may isang pamamaraan na tinatawag na iterative phase estimation, na kinabibilangan ng pagpapatakbo ng mga circuit tulad ng mga nakita natin,
kasama ang ilang menor na mga pagbabago sa kanila, upang makabuo ng isang approximation sa theta.
Ngunit ilarawan ko
ang maaaring tawaging mas tradisyonal na diskarte, kung saan gumagamit tayo ng isang solong quantum circuit na may maraming control qubit
na kumokontrol ng iba't ibang
bilang ng mga pag-ulit ng unitary na operasyon U.
Una ay ilalarawan ko kung paano ito
gumagana para sa dalawang control qubit at pagkatapos ay kaunti mamaya ay gagalingin natin ito sa higit sa dalawang control qubit.
Narito ang isang quantum circuit
na gumagamit ng dalawang control qubit.
Ang nangungunang control qubit
ay kumokontrol ng isang solong U na operasyon habang ang pangalawa mula sa nangungunang qubit ay kumokontrol ng dalawang kopya ng U.
Kaya ang ginagawa natin ay pinagsasama ang dalawang circuit na nakita natin kanina, sa paraang gumagamit ng solong kopya
ng eigenvector psi na mayroon tayo.
Mapapansin mo gayunpaman
na ang mga Hadamard gate pagkatapos ng controlled U
na mga operasyon ay inalis at walang mga sukat pa.
Ang gagawin natin ay
makita kung paano gumagana ang circuit na ito at pagkatapos ay malalaman natin
kung ano ang dapat nating gawin sa nangungunang dalawang qubit
upang matuto nang hanggang kaya-kaya tungkol sa halagang theta na
sinusubukan nating i-approximate.
Pagkatapos ng mga Hadamard gate na isinagawa, mayroon tayo ng estado na
ipinapakita sa screen.
At ito ay magiging isang maginhawang paraan ng pagsusulat ng estado upang
makita kung ano ang mangyayari susunod.
Ang A zero at A isa ay mga bit, at kung iisipin natin ang nangungunang dalawang qubit bilang isang dalawang qubit na rehistro,
iniisip natin ang A zero, na tumutugma sa nangungunang qubit bilang ang mas mababang makabuluhang bit, at ang A isa na tumutugma
sa mas mababang control qubit
bilang ang mas mataas na makabuluhang bit.
Pagkatapos ng unang controlled
U na operasyon ay isinasagawa, nakukuha natin ang estadong ito.
Ang klasikal na estado na tumutugma sa nangungunang control qubit ay A zero, kaya ang resulta ng phase kickback
ay maaaring ipahayag sa ganitong paraan. Pagkatapos pagkatapos ng pangalawa at
ikatlong controlled U na mga operasyon
ay isinasagawa, nakukuha natin ang estadong ito.
Ang ideya ay pareho sa para sa una, maliban sa pagkakataong ito ini-apply natin ang control U na operasyon nang dalawang beses.
Kaya pinarami natin ang A isa ng dalawa sa
exponent upang ipakita ito.
At ngayon ay maaari nating pasimplehin ang expression na ito sa pamamagitan ng pag-iisip tungkol sa mga bit
A isa at A zero nang magkasama bilang isang integer sa pagitan ng zero at
tatlo gamit ang binary notation.
Iyon ay kapag nag-iisip tayo
tungkol sa dalawang bit string, A isa A zero, bilang ang binary
na encoding ng isang integer,
ang nakukuha natin ay dalawa
times A isa plus A zero.
At ang pag-unawa ay
na kapag sumulat tayo ng Cat X, pinag-uusapan natin ang X na nakasulat bilang isang binary string ng haba
na dalawa gamit ang binary notation.
Kaya ngayon tumuon tayo sa
dalawang control qubit na ito upang malaman kung ano ang
matututunan natin tungkol sa theta mula sa kanila sa puntong ito.
Ang natitirang N qubit ay
nasa parehong estado psi pa rin na orihinal na ibinigay sa atin, na talagang isang kahanga-hangang
bagay tungkol sa diskarteng ito
dahil tulad ng sinabi ko kanina, maaari nating gamitin muli ang estado na iyon kung gusto nating makakuha ng higit na
impormasyon tungkol sa theta.
Ngunit sa ngayon, isipin lang natin kung ano ang matututunan natin mula sa
dalawang control qubit na ito.
Upang matulungan tayong malaman kung paano magpatuloy, isipin natin na ipinangako sa atin na ang theta ay katumbas ng Y over four
para sa ilang integer y sa pagitan ng zero at tatlo.
Sa pangkalahatan, ang theta ay maaaring hindi
isa sa apat na halagang ito, ngunit ito ay isang natural na kaso na dapat isaalang-alang.
Nakita natin sa orihinal na solong control qubit na bersyon ng pamamaraan na kung ipinangako sa atin na ang theta ay alinman sa zero o kalahati
ang circuit ay ihahayag kung alin ito. At napansin din natin na sa bersyon kung saan ini-apply natin ang
controlled U na operasyon nang dalawang beses,
maaari tayong perpektong makilala ang kaso na ang theta equals zero mula sa kaso na ang theta
equals isang kapat.
Kaya maaari tayong umasa na sa ating bagong circuit ay maaari nating makilala ang apat na kasong ito.
Sa esensya, ang ginagawa natin ay
ginagamit natin ang konsepto ng isang promise problem
upang gawing mas madali ang problema, upang makita natin kung paano magpatuloy.
At hindi iyon isang masamang ideya, sa pangkalahatan. Kung mayroon kang problema at
hindi mo alam kung paano ito lutasin, subukang gawing mas madali.
Kung malulutas mo ang mas madaling problema, ang pananaw na makukuha mo ay maaaring makatulong sa paglutas ng mas pangkalahatang problema.
At kung hindi mo malulutas ang mas madaling problema, marahil ay hindi ka pa handa
para sa mas pangkalahatang problema.
Kaya magpatuloy sa paggawa nito nang mas madali
hanggang sa malutas mo ito.
Anyway, bumabalik sa ating problema, tukuyin natin ang isang dalawang qubit na estado para sa bawat isa sa mga posibleng halaga ng Y.
Sa ibang salita, ang phi Y ay katumbas ng estado
na ipinapakita sa itaas ng screen kapag ang theta ay pinili nang tiyak na maging Y over four.
At narito ang apat na estado na iyon na nakasulat nang malinaw.
Kaya para lang ulitin, kung
ang theta ay katumbas ng Y over four para sa Y na zero, isa, dalawa, o
tatlo at pinapatakbo natin ang ating circuit,
maiiwan tayo ng
isa sa apat na estadong ito, whichever isa ang tumutugma
sa tamang halaga ng Y.
At gusto lang nating malaman
kung alin ito.
At ang tanong ay, posible ba ito?
At ang sagot sa tanong na iyon ay oo, dahil ang apat na estadong ito ay orthogonal.
Kung kalkulahin mo ang inner product
sa pagitan ng anumang pares sa kanila, makakakuha ka ng zero.
At dahil sila ay orthogonal, maaari silang perpektong makilala sa pamamagitan ng isang projective measurement.
At partikular na maaari
nating ipahayag ang ganitong pagsukat sa pamamagitan ng pagtatakda ng isang projection para sa bawat vector tulad ng mayroon tayo dito.
Ito ay palaging gumagana, sa tuwing
mayroon tayong isang orthonormal na batayan, at maaari mong suriin ito
laban sa mga kahulugan na nakita natin sa aralin tatlo
para sa espesipikong kasong ito
kung gusto mo. Kaya nagtatanda tayo na posible
na maisakatuparan ang ating gawain,
na ang matuto ng halaga ng Y mula sa estadong ipinapakita
sa itaas ng screen.
At kung gusto nating gawin iyon
gamit ang isang quantum circuit, maaari tayong magpatuloy tulad ng ilalarawan ko ngayon.
Una ay maaari tayong tumukoy ng isang unitary matrix V na ang mga column ay ang apat na
vector na nakalista sa pagkakasunud-sunod.
Ang matrix na iyon ay magkakaroon ng aksyon na inilarawan sa ibaba ng screen,
sa mga standard basis state,
at maaari nating isulat ang matrix
upang makita kung ano ang hitsura nito.
Dahil ang V ay nagmamapa ng bawat standard basis state, kappa Y sa vector na phi Y, mayroon tayo na sa pamamagitan ng pag-apply ng V dagger,
o sa ibang salita ang V inverse sa phi Y ay magbabago pabalik sa kabilang paraan sa kaukulang standard basis state.
Kaya ang maaari nating gawin ay ang pag-apply ng V dagger sa anumang estado na
nakuha natin mula sa ating circuit.
At pagkatapos kung magsasagawa tayo ng isang
standard basis measurement, makukuha natin ang numero Y
na hinahanap natin, na ipinahayag bilang isang string
ng haba na dalawa sa binary.
Bago tayo magpatuloy, pag-usapan natin nang kaunti pa
ang tungkol sa unitary matrix V.
Ito ay isang espesyal na matrix at
maaaring nakita mo na ito kanina.
Ito ang matrix na kaugnay
sa isang linear na operasyon sa apat na dimensional na mga vector na kilala bilang discrete Fourier transform.
Upang maging mas tumpak, ang discrete Fourier transform ay maaaring tukuyin para sa anumang
positibong integer na dimensyon, at titingnan natin ito
sa pangkalahatan sa ilang sandali.
At ito ang hitsura nito nang tiyak kapag ang dimensyon ay katumbas ng apat.
Maaari tayong mag-isip tungkol sa
discrete Fourier transform sa iba't ibang paraan.
Maaari nating isipin ito nang purong abstrakto bilang isang linear na pagmamapa sa mga vector na maaaring katawanin ng isang matrix.
At maaari rin nating isipin
ito bilang isang computational na problema kung saan binibigyan tayo ng isang vector, at gusto nating kalkulahin ang resulta
ng pag-apply ng linear na pagmamapang ito.
Lumalabas na ito ay isang napakahalagang
computational na problema, at mayroong isang lubhang mahusay na algorithm para sa pagsasagawa ng kalkulasyong iyon
na kilala bilang fast Fourier transform.
Sa katunayan, ito ay napaka-importanteng problema sa signal processing halimbawa, na ang fast Fourier
transform ay itinuturing ng marami
na isa sa pinaka-mahalaga at makabuluhang
mga algorithm na natuklasan.
Maaari rin nating isipin ang
discrete Fourier transform bilang isang unitary quantum na operasyon na maaaring ilapat sa
isang quantum state vector.
At kapag iniisip natin ito sa ganitong paraan, tinatawag natin ito na quantum Fourier
transform, o QFT para sa maikli.
Sa matematika, ito ay karaniwang parehong bagay tulad ng discrete Fourier transform, ngunit tinatawag natin itong quantum Fourier transform
para lang linawin na ito ay isang operasyon na inilalapat sa isang quantum state vector.
Kaya baguhin natin ang pangalan ng ating matrix, mula V hanggang QFT four upang ipakita ang katotohanan
na ang operasyong nabuo natin ay ang quantum Fourier transform.
Kaya narito ang kumpletong circuit para sa pag-aaral ng halaga ng Y kapag ipinangako sa atin na
ang theta equals Y over four
para sa Y na zero, isa, dalawa, o tatlo.
At para lang matiyak na malinaw ito, ini-apply natin ang inverse ng
quantum Fourier transform, o sa ibang salita QFT four dagger
upang maimapa ang isa sa apat na posibleng estado pabalik sa standard basis state, cat Y, upang mabawi natin ang Y sa pamamagitan ng pagsukat.
Kaya iyon ang circuit na
nakukuha natin mula sa pag-iisip tungkol sa promised na bersyon ng
phase estimation problem, kung saan ipinangako sa atin na ang theta
ay zero, isang kapat, isang
kalahati, o tatlong kapat, ngunit walang pumipigil sa atin
na patakbuhin ang circuit na ito para sa
isang arbitrary na halaga ng theta.
At kung gagawin natin iyon, narito
ang mga probabilidad para sa apat na posibleng
resulta na nakukuha natin.
Ang bawat isa sa apat na posibleng
halaga para sa Y ay may sariling kulay, at ang plot ay nagsasabi sa atin
kung ano ang mga probabilidad para sa bawat isa bilang isang function ng theta.
Halimbawa, kung ang theta
ay katumbas ng tatlong kapat, makakakuha tayo ng resulta
na tatlo na may probabilidad na isa,
habang ang mga probabilidad para sa tatlo pang resulta ay lahat ng zero tulad ng alam na natin mula sa pag-iisip tungkol sa promised na bersyon ng problema.
Kung ang theta ay malapit sa tatlong kapat ngunit hindi eksakto tatlong kapat, magkakaroon ng ilang hindi-zero na probabilidad na kaugnay sa mga ibang resulta,
ngunit makakakuha pa rin tayo ng resulta
na tatlo na may mataas na probabilidad.
Kaya kahit na ang theta ay maaaring hindi katumbas ng Y over four, maaari pa rin nating isipin
ang resulta na nakukuha natin mula sa mga sukat na hinati ng apat
bilang isang hula o isang
approximation para sa theta.
Ang hula ay maaaring mali, ngunit gayunpaman ito ay
nagbibigay sa atin ng impormasyon.
At isang bagay na
maaari nating matutunan mula sa plot ay na ang pinakamainam na mga approximation ay palaging may pinakamataas na
mga probabilidad na kaugnay sa kanila.
Kapag sinabi ko ang pinakamainam na approximation, ibig sabihin ko anumang halaga ng Y over four ang pinaka-malapit sa tunay na halaga ng theta,
sa modular one na kahulugan. Ang pinakamasamang posibleng kaso ay ang theta ay eksaktong nasa kalagitnaan sa pagitan ng
dalawang halaga ng Y over four.
Halimbawa, kung ang theta ay katumbas ng
tatlong kaliwa o 0.375, sa kasong ito makikita natin
na ang mga approximation
na isang kapat at dalawang kapat
o kalahati ay pantay na mabuti.
Kaya sa partikular na
kasong ito ay talagang may dalawang pinakamainam na approximation kaysa sa isa.
At pantay-pantay ang posibilidad na makuha natin ang resulta na isa
at ang resulta na dalawa.
Ang dalawa pang resulta na zero at tatlo, na hindi nagbibigay ng napakagandang
mga approximation sa theta kapag hinati natin ng apat, ay talagang lumalabas na may ilang probabilidad
na tila halos
10% lang sa magkabilang kaso.
Kaya ang pamamaraang ito ay hindi perpekto, ngunit nagbibigay ito sa atin ng impormasyon.
At kapansin-pansin na
anuman ang theta, palagi tayong garantisadong makakakuha ng pinakamainam na approximation
o isa sa dalawang pinakamainam na approximation kapag may ugnayan, na may probabilidad na
tila higit kumulang 40%.
At habang mas malapit ang theta
sa approximation, mas mataas ang probabilidad na makita ang kaukulang halaga ng Y.
At iyon ay isang medyo
malaking pagpapabuti kaysa sa paggamit ng isang solong control qubit.
Ito ay sa katunayan ang phase
estimation procedure kapag pinili nating gumamit ng dalawang control qubit.
At ang susunod na gagawin natin ay gagalingin ito
nang natural na paraan, kung saan hindi tayo titigil sa
dalawang control qubit lamang
kundi gagamit tayo ng gaano karaming
control qubit ang gusto natin.
At makikita natin na sa pamamagitan ng
paggalin ng pamamaraan, sa pamamagitan ng pagdaragdag ng higit pang mga control qubit, magagawa tayong makakuha ng higit at higit na
tumpak na mga approximation ng theta. At iyon ang magiging pangkalahatang
phase estimation procedure.
Upang gagalingin ang
phase estimation procedure mula sa dalawang control qubit
hanggang sa gaano karami ang gusto natin, kakailanganin nating maunawaan
kung paano tinukoy ang quantum Fourier transform para sa iba pang mga dimensyon.
At kakailanganin din nating talakayin kung paano ito maisasagawa
gamit ang isang quantum circuit.
Narito ang kahulugan ng
quantum Fourier transform kapag ang dimensyon ay isang
arbitrary na positibong integer N.
Dito iniisip natin ang operasyong ito bilang isang operasyon sa isang sistema na ang mga klasikal na estado ay
zero hanggang N minus isa.
At dito ang matrix na
naglarawan ng operasyong ito ay ipinahayag gamit ang
direct notation.
Maaari rin nating ilarawan ito sa mga tuntunin ng aksyon nito
sa mga standard basis state, para lang ikonekta ito sa
kung ano ang nakita na natin kapag ang N ay katumbas ng apat.
Kaya narito kung ano ang hitsura nito kapag ang N ay katumbas ng isa, na hindi isang napaka-kawili-wiling kaso.
Narito ito para sa N ay katumbas ng dalawa, at mapapansin mo kung ano ang nakukuha natin sa kasong ito ay isang Hadamard na operasyon.
Narito ang quantum Fourier
transform para sa N equals tatlo.
Para sa N equals apat, na
nakita na natin.
At para sa isang huling halimbawa, narito ito kapag ang N ay katumbas ng walo.
Tulad ng mayroon tayo kanina
para sa kaso ng N equals apat, ito ang mga matrix na itinutukoy natin sa discrete Fourier transform
para sa bawat isa sa mga dimensyon. Ngunit tinatawag natin itong
quantum Fourier transform kapag gusto nating isipin ito
bilang isang quantum na operasyon.
Minsan sa pamamagitan ng paraan, ang nangungunang kadahilanan na isa sa square root ng N ay hindi kasama kapag iniisip natin ang discrete Fourier
transform bilang isang matrix,
ngunit kailangan natin ng kadahilanang iyon dito upang matiyak na makakakuha tayo ng unitary matrix.
May ilang negatibong tanda rin minsan sa bawat exponent, ngunit hindi palagi.
Ito ay karaniwang isang personal na kagustuhan lamang na hindi nagbabago sa pundamental
na kalikasan ng transform.
Ngunit sa anumang kaso, tutukuyin natin ang quantum Fourier transform tulad ng nakasulat dito sa screen.
May isang napaka-kapaki-pakinabang na shorthand
notation na karaniwan at gagamitin natin ito
kaunti mamaya sa aralin.
At iyon ay ang pagtatakda ng isang
complex na numero omega N, tulad ng mayroon tayo dito.
Partikular bilang e sa dalawang pi I over N, na maaari ring isulat
gamit ang mga sine at cosine
tulad ng mayroon tayo dito. Minsan tinatawag natin ang numerong ito na N through of unity dahil kapag itinataas natin ito
sa kapangyarihang N, nakakakuha tayo ng isa.
Narito ang isang pigura na nagpapakita ng ilang mga halimbawa.
Ang Omega isa ay katumbas ng isa, ang omega dalawa ay katumbas ng negatibong isa, at ang omega apat ay katumbas ng I.
Sa pangkalahatan upang makuha ang omega N, maaari nating isipin ang paghahati sa unit circle sa N pantay na laki ng piraso tulad ng isang pizza na ibinabahagi ng N na tao
at ang omega N ay nasa
sulok ng unang piraso, ipinagpapalagay na ang iba pang sulok
ng piraso ay nasa isa.
Kaya partikular habang ang N
ay nagiging mas malaki at mas malaki, ang mga piraso ay magiging mas maliit at mas maliit, at ang omega N ay magiging
mas malapit at mas malapit sa isa.
At ngayon kung gagamitin natin ang notasyong iyon ay maaari nating ipahayag ang
quantum Fourier transform sa medyo mas malinis na paraan.
Minsan ang notasyong ito
ay tumutulong na panatilihing simple ang mga bagay tulad ng makikita nating mangyayari
kaunti mamaya sa aralin.
May isang mahusay na quantum
circuit na pagpapatupad ng quantum Fourier transform
kapag ang N ay isang kapangyarihan ng dalawa,
na titingnan natin ngayon. Bagaman karaniwang tinutukoy natin ang
quantum Fourier transform para sa anumang dimensyon N,
kailangan natin ito lamang
sa kaso na ang N ay isang kapangyarihan ng dalawa, upang gagalingin ang
phase estimation procedure.
Ang pagpapatupad ay gagamitin
ang controlled phase gauge na inilarawan tulad ng mayroon
tayo dito sa screen.
Mukhang dalawang
control na magkadugtong kasama ang isang numero na
alpha sa kasong ito.
At ang aksyon ng gate na ito ay inilarawan ng matrix na ipinapakita dito.
Ito ay literal na
mga controlled phase gate, ibig sabihin ay mayroon tayong isang control qubit na kumokontrol sa isang phase gate.
Nakita natin ang mga phase gate kanina sa aralin isa.
Ngunit para sa mga phase gate nang tiyak, hindi talaga mahalaga
kung aling qubit ang control at kung alin ang target.
At nakita natin iyon sa aralin dalawa, para sa espesipikong kaso ng isang Z gate.
At ngayon na mayroon na tayo sa konseptong iyon, maaari na tayong magpatuloy sa kung paano ang
quantum Fourier transform ay maaaring ipatupad.
Ang pagpapatupad ay recursive sa kalikasan at marahil ang pinakamadaling paraan
upang ilarawan ito sa simpleng mga tuntunin ay ang magbigay ng halimbawa na
madaling gagalingin.
Narito kung paano natin magagawa ito
kapag ang N ay katumbas ng 32.
Kaya may limang qubit.
Para maging malinaw, itinutukoy natin ang
mga standard basis state ng limang qubit na ito sa mga integer sa pagitan ng zero at 31 gamit ang binary notation.
Ang unang ginagawa natin ay ang pagsasagawa ng quantum Fourier
transform para sa N equals 16 sa lahat ng qubit maliban sa
pinaka-mababang makabuluhang qubit,
na ito ang nasa itaas. At iyon ang recursive
na bahagi ng konstruksyon.
Kaya upang maipatupad ang operasyong ito, kailangan nating sundin ang parehong
pattern ngunit na may isang mas kaunting qubit.
At sa base case ay
mayroon lamang tayong isang solong qubit para sa kung saan ang quantum Fourier transform ay isang Hadamard gate lamang.
Kapag ini-apply na natin ang QFT sa lahat ng qubit maliban sa nangungunang isa, nag-a-apply tayo ng maraming controlled phase gate gamit ang mga phase na
ipinahiwatig sa diagram.
Pagkatapos ay nag-a-apply tayo ng Hadamard
gate sa nangungunang qubit, at inililipat ang mga qubit nang kaunti gamit ang ilang swap gate.
Ang mga swap gate na ito ay may epekto ng cyclic na pag-permute ng mga qubit na kailangan upang gumana
ang konstruksyon.
Maaari nating sundin ang eksaktong parehong pattern para sa iba pang mga pagpili ng N
basta mga kapangyarihan ng dalawa, kung saan palagi tayong nagsisimula sa
mga controlled phase gate
na may alpha na pi over
dalawa para sa pinakamababang qubit at hinihati ng dalawa sa bawat pagkakataon
na gumagalaw sa kaliwa sa diagram
upang makuha ang mga kasunod na phase. Ngayon ay hindi talaga maliwanag
na gumagana ang konstruksyong ito.
At hindi ko ipapaliwanag
kung bakit ito gumagana sa video na ito.
Kung interesado kang makita
ang mga detalye kung bakit ito gumagana, mahahanap mo ang mga ito sa
nakasulat na nilalaman para sa aralin.
Sasabihin ko gayunpaman na
ang pinagsamantalahan dito ay ang pangunahing istraktura ng
discrete Fourier transform
at sa katunayan ito ay eksakto
ang parehong istraktura na nagpapahintulot sa fast
Fourier transform na gumana.
Isa pang paraan upang sabihin ito ay na kung titingnan natin ang fast Fourier transform, maaari nating isipin ito sa mga tuntunin ng mga quantum circuit.
At ito ang circuit na makukuha natin.
Kaya ilang gate ang kailangan natin sa kabuuan para sa pagpapatupad na ito?
Upang malaman iyon, hayaan nating ang SM ay ang bilang ng mga gate na
kailangan natin kapag mayroon tayong M qubit.
Kapag ang M ay katumbas ng isa, kailangan lang natin ng isang solong gate dahil ang QFT ay isang Hadamard na operasyon lamang sa kasong ito.
Kung ang M ay hindi bababa sa dalawa, kung gayon ito
ang mga gate na kailangan natin.
Una ay kailangan natin ng SM minus isa na gate para sa quantum Fourier
transform sa M minus isa qubit, anuman ang maging numerong iyon.
Kailangan din natin ng M minus isa
na controlled phase gate, M minus isa na swap gate,
at isa pang karagdagang Hadamard gate.
Kaya narito ang isang expression
ng SM sa magkabilang kaso kapag ang M ay katumbas ng isa at
kapag ang M ay hindi bababa sa dalawa.
Ito ay isang halimbawa ng tinatawag na recurrence relation at
napaka-karaniwan nila sa pagsusuri ng mga algorithm.
Ang partikular na ito
ay nangyayaring napaka-simple at ito ay may tinatawag na
closed form expression, na maaari nating makuha sa pamamagitan ng pagbubuod.
Upang maging tumpak, ang halaga ng SM ay ang kabuuan ng unang M
sunud-sunod na mga kakaibang integer, na katumbas ng M squared,
tulad ng maaaring natuklasan mo kanina o marahil ay napansin mo lang iyon
sa ilang punto sa iyong buhay.
At napaka-madaling patunayan na ang formula na ito ay totoo sa pamamagitan ng induction sa M kung
interesado ka sa isang pormal na patunay.
Kaya iyon na. Maaari nating ipatupad ang
quantum Fourier transform sa M qubit gamit ang M squared na gate.
Ilan lang na napaka-
maikling karagdagang mga puna.
Una ay hindi talaga
natin kailangan ang lahat ng swap gate na inilarawan ko.
Posibleng epektibo
itulak ang lahat ng ito sa dulo basta in-adjust natin kung aling qubit ang gumagawa ang mga controlled phase gate
ayon nang naaayon.
At kung gagawin natin iyon ay kakailanganin lang natin ng
M over dalawa na swap gate sa kabuuan na binabalik-baligtad pababa.
Magkakaroon pa rin tayo ng quadratic na gastos, ngunit ang bilang ng mga gate ay maaaring bawasan sa ganitong paraan.
At isang panghuling puna ay na maaari pa nating bawasan ang gastos kung handa tayong magtanggap ng
medyo magandang approximation.
Halimbawa, kapag ang M ay nagiging malaki, marami sa mga controlled phase gate ay medyo malapit sa
identity na operasyon,
at ang pag-aalis ng
mga napaka-malapit na iyon ay makapagmakatipid sa atin ng maraming gate habang nagbibigay pa rin sa atin ng
medyo magandang approximation.
Posible rin na i-approximate ang quantum Fourier transform
gamit ang napaka-mababaw na mga circuit, ibig sabihin ang mga may maliit na lalim, kung sakaling iyon ang
gusto nating gawin.
At ngayon na alam na natin kung ano ang
quantum Fourier transform para sa iba't ibang mga dimensyon, pati na rin kung paano ito maisasagawa kapag ang dimensyon ay isang kapangyarihan ng dalawa,
maaari tayong bumalik sa
phase estimation procedure at makita kung paano ito maaaring gagalingin kung saan gumagamit tayo ng ilang arbitrary
na bilang M ng control qubit.
Narito kung ano ang hitsura ng pamamaraan bilang isang quantum circuit para sa
isang arbitrary na pagpili ng M.
Mayroon tayong M control qubit sa itaas, na ipinapalagay natin ay lahat
na-initialize sa zero na estado.
Nag-a-apply tayo ng Hadamard
gate sa bawat isa sa kanila at pagkatapos ang bawat isa sa kanila ay
ginagamit bilang isang control qubit upang mag-apply ng ilang kapangyarihan ng
unitary na operasyon U,
kung saan dino-double natin ang bilang
ng beses na ini-apply ang U para sa bawat control qubit.
Dito sa diagram na ito ipinahiwatig ko ito sa pamamagitan ng pagsasama ng mga kapangyarihan
sa U sa loob ng mga kahon kaysa sa pagpapakita ng controlled U gate
na ini-apply nang ganoong maraming beses, bilang isang paraan ng parehong paggawa
ng diagram na mas malinaw at pagtitipid sa espasyo upang
magkasya ito sa screen.
Ngayon ang unang bagay na kailangan nating pansinin
tungkol sa pamamaraang ito ay maaari itong maging napaka-mahal.
Partikular na
dino-double natin ang bilang ng beses na ini-apply ang bawat U na operasyon
para sa bawat control qubit.
At kung ang paraan ng paggawa natin nito ay ang simpleng pag-ulit ng isang controlled U gate kahit ilang beses na kailangan natin,
makakakuha tayo ng napakalaking circuit. Ito ay magiging exponentially
malaki sa bilang M.
Iyon ay isang pangunahing limitasyon sa pangkalahatan, at partikular na nililimitahan nito ang ating kakayahan na makakuha ng tumpak na mga approximation
ng mga eigenvalue.
Sa espesipikong kaso ng factoring gayunpaman, na maaabot natin sa ilang sandali, lumalabas na tayo ay napakapalad at maaari tayong maglaro ng isang trick na nagpapahintulot sa atin
na maiwasan ang exponential na pagtaas na ito sa gastos.
Ngunit sa pangkalahatan para sa mga arbitrary
na unitary na operasyon U, hindi ito magiging posible at
mababayaran tayo ng mataas na presyo
para sa pagdaragdag ng
bilang ng mga control qubit.
Hindi ko dadaanin
ang isang detalyadong pagsusuri ng circuit sa video na ito at sa halip ay banggitin ko lang na may medyo simpleng
expression para sa estado
nang wala pang sandali bago ang mga sukat na ipinapakita dito sa screen.
Mula sa estado na iyon maaari tayong makakuha ng isang expression para sa mga probabilidad
ng iba't ibang mga resulta, at ito ang hitsura nito.
At kapag mayroon na tayo ng expression na ito,
maaari tayong makatuwiran tungkol dito, at talagang ang expression na ito
ay lahat ng kailangan natin upang magpatuloy.
Tulad ng sinabi ko, hindi ko tatalakayin
ang mga detalye sa video na ito, ngunit mahahanap mo ang mga ito sa
nakasulat na nilalaman para sa aralin at lumalabas na ito ay
hindi naman masyadong kumplikado,
kaya tingnan mo kung interesado ka. Kung dadaanin natin ang pagsusuri, mahahanap natin na ang sitwasyon
ay hindi masyadong naiiba
mula sa kaso ng M equals dalawa, maliban na makakakuha tayo ng mas maraming katumpakan.
Partikular na, maaari tayong isaalang-alang nang una
ang probabilidad na makuha ang pinakamainam o isa sa
dalawang pinakamainam na approximation,
na maaari nating ipahayag tulad ng mayroon tayo dito.
Maaari mong balewalain ang subscript na isa sa absolute na halaga kung gusto mo.
Ito ay isang simbolo lamang na
maaari nating gamitin upang paalalahanan ang ating sarili na pinag-uusapan natin ang
mga approximation sa bilog kung saan iniisip natin ang theta equals zero
at theta equals isa bilang pareho. Ang punto dito ay
iniisip natin ang anumang pagpili ng Y na gumagawa ng Y over dalawa sa kapangyarihang M
na kasing lapit hanggang kaya-kaya sa theta.
At muli, tulad ng mayroon tayo
para sa kaso ng M equals dalawa, garantisado tayong makuha ang resultang Y na ito na may probabilidad na hindi bababa sa 40%.
Sa katunayan, ang probabilidad ay
hindi bababa sa apat sa pi squared, na medyo higit sa 40%.
Ang 10 ay hindi isang masamang
approximation sa pi squared kapag nagmamadali ka.
At iyon ay talagang kamangha-mangha. Ang pinag-uusapan natin ay ang pagkuha ng pinakamainam na
approximation sa theta bilang isang fraction Y over dalawa sa kapangyarihang M
kung saan ang Y ay isang integer. At nakukuha natin ang
pinakamainam na approximation na may probabilidad na higit sa 40%.
Maaari rin nating isaalang-alang ang
mga approximation na mas masamang-mabuti.
Partikular na, isipin natin
na ang Y ay hindi gaanong mabuti, at mas partikular na ipagpalagay natin
na may mas magandang
approximation sa theta ng parehong anyo na nasa pagitan ng theta at Y over dalawa sa M,
na maaaring ipahayag
tulad ng nakasulat sa screen.
Sa ganitong kaso ang
probabilidad na makuha ang Y na ito ay magiging medyo maliit, kadalasan ay 25%.
Talagang mas mababa kaysa doon, ngunit ang 25% ang makukuha natin mula sa
medyo simpleng pagsusuri, ngunit sapat na ito.
Bilang isang halimbawa. Narito ang plot na nakukuha natin kapag gumagamit tayo ng tatlong control
qubit kaysa sa dalawa.
Sa pagkakataong ito ay
nagpo-plot lamang ako ng mga probabilidad para sa mga resulta na tatlo, apat, at lima dahil hindi ko gusto ang
pigura na maging masyadong malabo.
Kapag ang theta ay katumbas ng
kalahati halimbawa, garantisado tayong makuha ang resulta na apat.
At kaya ang ating
approximation ay apat sa walo o kalahati dahil dalawa sa
kapangyarihang tatlo ay walo.
At sa kasong ito tayo ay eksakto. At hangga't ang theta ay mas malapit sa kalahati kaysa sa halimbawa tatlong
kaliwa,
nakukuha natin ang resulta na apat na may probabilidad na mas mataas
kaysa sa resulta na tatlo.
At na may probabilidad,
muli na mas malaki sa 40%.
Narito ang plot kapag ang M ay katumbas ng apat. At ang mga kurba ay talagang
mukhang halos magkapareho, maliban na ngayon ay mag-zoom in tayo ng dalawang beses.
Kaya ngayon ang mga resulta na naka-plot ay kinabibilangan ng pito, walo, at siyam at kinukuha natin ang approximation na isa sa mga numerong ito
na hinati ng 16 kaysa sa walo.
At magpapakita pa ako ng isa pang plot kung saan tataas tayo sa M equals lima.
At muli ay
mag-zoom in tayo ng dalawang beses.
At narito ito. Muli ang mga kurba ay mukhang
halos magkapareho, ngunit epektibo nating
dino-double ang ating katumpakan.
At tulad ng dati ay nakukuha natin ang pinakamainam na approximation sa theta, na may probabilidad na higit sa 40%.
Iyon ay kamangha-mangha. Ngunit kung ang 40% ay hindi sapat
bilang isang sukatan ng kumpiyansa,
ang maaari nating gawin ay ang patakbuhin ang pamamaraan nang maliit na bilang ng beses, at
kunin ang mode ng mga resulta, ibig sabihin ang isa na
lumalabas nang pinaka-madalas.
At kung gagawin natin iyon, magiging lubhang malamang na makakamit natin ng isang napakagandang approximation sa theta.
Alalahanin sa pamamagitan ng paraan na sa tuwing pinapatakbo natin ang
phase estimation procedure ay mayroon tayong eigenvector
na lumalabas nang hindi nagbabago.
Kaya available ito para sa atin na patakbuhin ang pamamaraan
nang maraming beses tulad nito.
Sa madaling salita, nangongolekta tayo ng
mga istatistika tungkol sa theta, at ang punto ay na sa pamamagitan ng paggawa nito ay maaari tayong makakuha ng napaka-tumpak na
approximation sa theta
na may napataas na kumpiyansa, at hindi tayo kailangan ng maraming pag-ulit ng pamamaraan upang gawin ito.
At iyon ang paraan ng pagtatrabaho ng phase
estimation procedure.
Sa huling bahagi ng aralin, ilalapat natin ang pamamaraan
ng phase estimation sa problema ng integer factorization.
Tulad ng nabanggit ko sa simula ng video, ang paraan ng pagtatrabaho nito ay isinasaalang-alang natin ang isang intermediate na problema na kilala bilang order finding problem.
Makikita natin kung paano natin malulutas
ang order finding problem gamit ang phase estimation, at pagkatapos ay maikling tatalakayin natin kung paano ang paglutas sa order finding problem
ay nagpapahintulot sa atin na mag-factor ng mga integer nang mahusay.
Ang pangalawang bahagi ay ganap na klasikal at ibubuod ko lamang ang
pangunahing ideya sa video na ito.
Ngunit magsimula tayo sa
order finding problem.
Una, kunin natin ang ilang
maginhawang notation.
Para sa bawat positibong integer N, tinutukoy natin ang ZN bilang ang mga integer
zero hanggang N minus isa.
Halimbawa, ang Z isa ay may isang
solong elemento na zero, ang Z dalawa ay may mga elemento na zero at isa,
ang Z tatlo ay may mga elemento na zero,
isa at dalawa, at iba pa.
Kaya ang ZN ay isang set.
Ngunit maaari rin nating isipin
ito bilang higit sa isang set. Maaari tayong mag-isip tungkol sa mga operasyon sa aritmetika tulad ng pagdaragdag at pagpaparami sa ZN
sa pamamagitan ng pagtatakda ng mga ito modular N.
Halimbawa, ipagpalagay nating
ang N ay katumbas ng pito.
Mayroon tayong tatlo at lima
na mga elemento ng Z pito at kung pinaramin natin sila makukuha natin ang 15
na nag-iiwan ng natitira na
isa pagkatapos na hatiin ng pito.
Minsan ipinahahayag natin ito sa pamamagitan ng pagsusulat na ang tatlo times lima ay
congruent sa isa modulo pito, tulad ng nakasulat dito.
Ngunit maaari rin nating isulat lamang na ang tatlo times lima ay katumbas ng isa.
Siyempre ang tatlo times lima
ay hindi karaniwan na katumbas ng isa, ito ay katumbas ng 15.
Ngunit kapag malinaw na
nagtatrabaho tayo sa Z pito ibig sabihin na ang pagpaparami
ay tinukoy na modular pito,
maaari tayong simpleng sumulat na
ang tatlo times lima ay katumbas ng isa.
Ngayon sa mga elemento
ng ZN para sa anumang positibong N, ang ilan sa kanila ay magkakaroon ng
GCD na katumbas ng isa sa N
at ang ilan ay hindi magkakaroon. At ang mga elementong may GCD na katumbas ng isa sa N ay espesyal.
at isinusulat natin ang ZN star upang sumangguni sa set ng mga elementong ito lamang.
Halimbawa, narito ang Z 21 star.
Sa mga elemento ng Z 21, na mayroong 21 siyempre, lumalabas na ang 12 sa kanila ay may GCD na katumbas ng isa
sa 21 at ang natitira ay wala.
Partikular na sa tuwing mayroon tayong isang elemento ng Z 21 na nahahati sa alinman sa
tatlo o pito, nilalaktawan natin ito.
Mayroong iba't ibang dahilan
kung bakit espesyal ang set na ito, at isa sa mga dahilan ay na sa tuwing mayroon tayong isang elemento ng ZN star
at isinasaalang-alang natin ang mga positibong
integer na kapangyarihan ng numerong iyon, palagi tayong sa huli
maaabot ang numero na isa,
kung saan tulad ng dati ay pinag-uusapan natin ang pagpaparami na modular N.
ang pinakamaliit na positibong integer na kapangyarihan na nagbibigay sa atin ng isa ay tinatawag
na order ng elementong iyon.
Halimbawa, isipin ang elemento na A equals apat sa Z 21 star.
apat times apat ay 16, na hindi katumbas ng isa modular ng 21, ngunit kung pararamin natin ng apat ng isa pang beses,
makukuha natin ang 64, at ang 64 modular
21 ay katumbas ng isa.
Kaya ang order ng apat na modular 21 ay tatlo.
Ang pag-abot sa isa tulad nito ay palaging nangyayari para sa lahat ng elemento ng ZN star.
At sa pamamagitan ng paraan, hindi ito kailanman
nangyayari para sa mga elemento ng ZN na wala sa ZN star.
Kaya ang pagkakaroon ng GCD na katumbas ng
isa sa N tulad nito ay parehong kinakailangan at
sapat para dito na mangyari.
At para lang tapusin ang
halimbawa ng N equals 21, narito ang pinakamaliit na
positibong integer na kapangyarihan para sa kung saan gumagana ito para sa
bawat elemento ng Z 21 star,
at maaari itong suriin nang isa-isa.
At ngayon ay maaari na nating isahaysay ang
order finding problem, na simpleng hanapin ang order para sa isang ibinigay na elemento sa ZN star.
Upang maging tumpak, ang input ay
dalawang positibong integer na A at N para sa kung saan ang GCD ay katumbas ng isa,
at ang output ay ang
pinakamaliit na positibong integer R na ang A sa kapangyarihang R ay
congruent sa isa modular N,
o katumbas nito ang
pinakamaliit na positibong integer R para sa kung saan ang A sa R ay katumbas ng isa.
Ipinagpapalagay na gumagawa tayo ng aritmetika sa ZN.
Ito ay pinaniniwalaan na isang
computationally na mahirap na problema, walang mahusay na klasikal na algorithm
ang kilala para sa paglutas nito.
At tulad ng tatalakayin natin ang problema ay hindi bababa sa kasing hirap ng
integer factorization sa kahulugan na kung mayroon tayong algorithm para sa paglutas ng order finding,
magagamit natin ang algorithm na iyon upang malutas ang integer
factorization problem nang mahusay.
Sa katunayan, pumupunta rin ito sa kabilang paraan, ibig sabihin na kung mayroon kang algorithm para sa factoring, maaari mo itong gamitin upang malutas
ang order finding problem.
Kaya ang dalawang problema ay
sa ilang kahulugan katumbas sa mga tuntunin ng kanilang
computational na kahirapan.
Ngayon makikita natin kung paano natin malulutas
ang order finding problem sa isang quantum computer
gamit ang phase estimation.
Upang gumawa ng koneksyon sa pagitan ng mga problema, isipin nating mayroon tayong isang sistema na ang klasikal na state set ay AN.
Para sa anumang pagpili ng isang elemento A sa ZN star, tutukuyin natin ang isang operasyon
MA tulad ng mayroon tayo dito.
Sa mga salita ang ginagawa ng MA ay ang pag-multiply ng A, at dito ang pagpaparami ay modular N.
At para sa natitirang bahagi ng araling ito, dapat mong palaging isipin ang
mga expression sa loob ng mga cat bilang kinakalkula modular N,
para lang panatilihing simple ang mga bagay at hindi na natin kailangang patuloy na
isulat ang mod N nang paulit-ulit.
Ito ay isang unitary na operasyon, ngunit iyon ay totoo lamang
dahil ang A ay nasa ZN star.
Kung ang GCD ng A at N ay hindi isa, ang operasyong ito ay hindi magiging unitary.
Narito ang isang halimbawa. Kung ang N ay katumbas ng 15 at ang A ay katumbas ng dalawa, na nasa Z 15 star, kung gayon
ito ang aksyon ng M dalawa.
At kung susuriin mo ang
halimbawa nang ilang sandali, makikita mo na ang nangyayari ay ang mga elemento ng ZN ay pinahihintulutan lamang ng aksyong ito.
Kaya parehong tiyak at unitary, na ibig sabihin ay bilang isang matrix, ang MA ay isang permutation matrix.
At narito ang pangunahing ideya. Ang mga eigenvalue ng MA ay
lubhang malapit na konektado
sa order ng A. At sa pamamagitan ng paggamit ng phase estimation upang i-approximate ang mga
eigenvalue na sapat na malapit
ay matutukoy natin ang order ng A. Kaya ano mismo ang mga eigenvector at eigenvalue ng MA?
Well, hindi natin kailangan ang lahat ng ito, kailangan natin ang ilan lang sa kanila.
Magsimula tayo sa isang madaling halimbawa.
Narito ang isang eigenvector ng MA, pinangalanan natin itong sukat zero, at ito ay ibinibigay ng
kabuuan ng cat isa, cat a,
cat A squared, at iba pa hanggang sa cat A sa kapangyarihang R minus isa, lahat na hinati ng square root ng R
upang gawin itong isang unit vector. Dito ang R ay ang order ng A.
At irereserba ko ang
titik R para sa order ng A para sa natitirang bahagi ng aralin.
Kaya sa tuwing makikita mo ang R, iyon ang order ng A para sa
anumang A na pinag-uusapan natin.
Ang eigenvalue na kaugnay
sa eigenvector na ito ay isa.
At maaari nating i-verify iyon sa pamamagitan ng
pag-apply ng MA sa vector na ito upang makita kung ano ang makukuha natin.
Ang MA ay nagpaparami ng A, kaya
kailangan lang nating dagdagan ang bawat exponent ng
isa at ito ang makukuha natin.
Ngunit ang order ng A ay R, kaya ang A sa kapangyarihang R ay katumbas ng isa.
At maaari nating gawin ang pagpapalit na iyon.
Ngunit iyon ay ang parehong vector
na sinimulan natin. Ginawa lang nating
i-shuffle ang mga cut sa paligid ngunit kinukuha natin ang kabuuan kaya
hindi ito nagbabago ng anuman.
Kaya ang MA times psi zero ay katumbas ng psi zero.
Kaya ito ay isang eigenvector ng
MA na may eigenvalue na isa.
Iyon ay isang napaka-simpleng
halimbawa ng isang eigenvector at upang matukoy ang higit pa sa kanila, alalahanin natin ang parehong notation na mayroon tayo kanina sa aralin.
Ang Omega R ay ang complex
na numero sa unit circle na nakukuha natin sa pamamagitan ng pagkuha ng E sa
kapangyarihang dalawa times pi times I
na hinati ng R. Noong nakaraan ay mayroon tayong N kaysa sa R, ngunit gumagana rin ito sa parehong
paraan para sa R sa halip na N.
Kailangan natin ang numerong ito dahil
ito ay lilitaw sa iba pang mga eigenvector
ng MA na matutukoy natin.
At ngayon na naalala na natin ang notasyong iyon, maaari nating obserbahan na ang vector na ito na pinangalanang psi isa ay isa ring eigenvector ng MA.
Ito ay katulad ng psi zero, mayroon tayong eksakto parehong mga cat at idinaragdag natin ang mga ito at
hinati ng square root ng R.
Ngunit sa pagkakataong ito ay mayroon tayong iba't ibang phase na nagpaparami sa bawat isa sa mga cat.
Ang Omega R sa negatibong isa para sa A, ang omega R sa negatibong dalawa para sa A squared, at iba pa hanggang sa omega R sa
kapangyarihang negatibong R minus isa
para sa A sa kapangyarihang R minus isa. Kaya ang kapangyarihan ng omega R
ay palaging negatibong isa times anumang kapangyarihan ng A
ang lumalabas sa loob ng cat.
Hindi ko dadaanin nang detalye, ngunit ito ay ipinapakita sa screen kung gusto mong muling panoorin ang video at i-pause ayon sa pangangailangan.
Ngunit kung gagawin natin ang pagpaparami at pasimplehin muli gamit ang katotohanan na ang A sa kapangyarihang R ay katumbas ng isa
pati na rin ang napaka-mahalagang katotohanan na ang omega sa kapangyarihang R ay katumbas ng isa, mahahanap nating mayroon tayo
muli ng isang eigenvector ng MA.
Sa pagkakataong ito habang ginagawa natin ang pagpapasimple, kakailanganin nating ilabas ang isang kadahilanan ng omega R upang makita na talagang mayroon tayong isang eigenvector
at ang vector na omega R ay kumakatawan sa eigenvalue na kaugnay sa eigenvector na ito.
Kaya iyon ay isang pangalawang eigenvector
eigenvalue pair ng NA.
Maaari tayong matukoy ng karagdagang mga eigenvector gamit ang eksakto parehong pangangatuwiran, At sa katunayan, kung simpleng papalitan natin ang omega R
ng omega R sa kapangyarihang J para sa bawat J sa pagitan ng zero at R minus isa, palagi tayong makakakuha ng eigenvector,
at ang kaukulang eigenvalue ay magiging omega R sa kapangyarihang J.
Kaya kasama talaga nito
ang psi zero at psi isa, na nakita na natin
pati na rin ang R minus dalawa, iba pang eigenvector, eigenvalue pair.
Gumagana ang lahat ng ito sa karaniwang parehong paraan, at upang i-verify ang mga ito, kailangan lang nating malaman na ang A sa kapangyarihang R ay katumbas ng isa
pati na rin ang omega R sa
kapangyarihang R ay katumbas ng isa.
Mayroong iba pang mga eigenvector ng MA tulad ng cat zero halimbawa, ngunit hindi sila magiging kapaki-pakinabang sa atin at hindi na natin kailangang mag-alala tungkol sa kanila.
Kailangan lang nating mag-alala tungkol sa psi zero hanggang psi R minus isa.
Tumuon tayo sa psi isa sa sandali, para lang subukang maunawaan kung bakit nagmamalasakit tayo sa mga eigenvector na ito
at kung ano ang maaari nilang sabihin sa atin
tungkol sa order R, na siyang sinusubukan nating hanapin.
Ipinagpapalagay na binibigyan tayo ng
eigenvector psi isa, maaari nating subukan na matuto
ng R sa sumusunod na paraan.
Una, nagsasagawa tayo ng phase
estimation sa eigenvector na ito gamit ang isang quantum circuit na
nagpapatupad ng operasyong MA.
Ang makukuha natin ay isang approximation sa theta, na isa sa R sa kasong ito.
At pangalawa dahil naghahanap tayo ng R at mayroon tayong isang
approximation sa isa sa R, ang natural na bagay na dapat gawin ay
ang kalkulahin ang reciprocal
at i-round ito off sa
pinakamalapit na integer. Kailangan nating i-round tulad nito
dahil ang R ay dapat na isang integer.
Ngunit wala tayong isa sa ating R nang eksakto, mayroon lang tayong isang approximation dito.
Ngunit kung ang approximation ay sapat na mabuti, makukuha natin ang R kapag nag-round tayo,
na iyon ang hinahanap natin.
At ngayon ang tanong ay gaano karaming katumpakan ang kailangan natin upang tumpak na matukoy ang R sa pamamagitan ng pagkalkula ng reciprocal at pag-round?
O sa ibang salita, gaano ka-tumpak ang kailangan ng ating
approximation upang gumana ang lahat?
Well, lumalabas na kailangan nga natin ng medyo tumpak na approximation.
Halimbawa, hindi natin
maaaring malito ang isa sa R sa isa sa R plus isa, o isa sa R minus isa halimbawa.
Sa dalawang fraction na iyon, ang isa sa R plus isa at
ang isa sa R minus isa ay medyo malapit sa isa
sa R kapag ang R ay malaki.
Ngunit kahit kailangan natin ng
medyo tumpak na approximation, hindi natin kailangan ng katawa-tawang
tumpak na approximation, at maaaring ipakita na
kung ang ating approximation
ay nakakatugon sa hindi pagkakapantay-pantay na
mayroon tayo dito sa screen, kung gayon ang pag-round off ay
magbibigay sa atin ng tamang sagot.
Hindi ko susubukang ipaliwanag iyon sa video na ito, ngunit ito ay ipinapakita sa nakasulat
na materyal para sa aralin kung interesado ka sa mga detalye.
At kung iyon ang katumpakan
na hinahanap natin, kung gayon sapat na ang gumamit ng isang
bilang ng control qubit sa phase estimation procedure
na katumbas ng dalawa times
ang haba ng N plus isa.
Kung saan tulad ng mayroon tayo sa mga nakaraang aralin, ang haba ng N ay ang bilang ng mga bit na kailangan natin upang ipahayag ang N sa binary.
Sa pamamagitan ng paraan, kung nasisiyahan tayo
na makuha ang pinakamainam na approximation na may probabilidad na hindi bababa sa 40% at hindi natin sinusubukang
dagdagan ang ating kumpiyansa
tulad ng inilarawan ko kanina, kung gayon hindi natin talagang kailangan ang plus isa.
Ngunit sa anumang kaso, mayroon tayong na ang bilang
ng mga control qubit na kailangan natin ay linear sa haba ng N
na nakasulat bilang isang binary string.
Nakita natin na kung mayroon tayo ng
eigenvector psi isa, maaari tayong gumamit ng phase estimation upang mahanap ang R, basta gumagamit tayo ng sapat na katumpakan.
Sa kasamaang palad ay hindi ganoon kadali na makuha ang eigenvector na ito.
Kaya magtanong tayo ng ibang tanong.
Ipagpalagay na wala tayong psi isa, ngunit sa halip ay mayroon tayong psi
para sa isang random na pagpili ng J.
Maaari pa rin ba nating malaman kung ano ang R? O kahit man lang maaari ba tayong
malaman ang isang bagay tungkol sa R?
At ang sagot ay oo, maaari tayong malaman ang isang bagay
tungkol sa R, kahit man lang sa karaniwan.
Ang maaari nating gawin ay subukan
na malaman ang J over R gamit ang napaka-katulad na paraan
sa nakita natin lamang,
ngunit may pangunahing pagkakaiba.
Una, gagawin natin nang eksakto ang
parehong bagay na ginawa natin kanina, na patakbuhin ang phase
estimation procedure sa eigenvector psi J.
At ang makukuha natin ay isang
approximation sa J over R, kumpara sa isa sa R,
na iyon ang mayroon tayo kanina.
Ngunit ngayon ay mayroon tayong isang maliit na problema, dahil ang pagkalkula ng
reciprocal ay hindi magbibigay sa atin ng R, magbibigay ito sa atin ng R over J.
At sa pamamagitan ng paraan, hindi natin
ipinapalagay na alam natin kung ano ang J, simpleng binibigyan lang tayo ng psi J para sa isang random na J,
at hindi sinasabi sa atin kung ano ang J. Kaya ano ang maaari nating gawin?
Well, lumalabas na may isang kilalang
klasikal na algorithm na makakatulong sa atin, na tinatawag na
continued fraction algorithm.
At ang magagawa ng algorithm na ito ay kunin ang ating approximation
Y over dalawa sa M at sabihin sa atin kung aling fraction U over V,
na nakasulat sa pinakamababang mga tuntunin, at kung saan ang U at V ay parehong
integer na mas maliit sa N ang pinaka-malapit sa ating approximation.
Ito ay isang talagang kahanga-hangang algorithm, at kung interesado ka dito, talagang dapat mong tingnan ito.
Ito ay malapit na konektado sa algorithm ni Euclid para sa
pagkalkula ng mga GCD sa katunayan.
Ngunit hindi na ako magdadagdag pa
tungkol dito sa video na ito.
Ang punto nito ay na kung mayroon tayong magandang
approximation sa ilang fraction para sa kung saan ang numerator at
denominator ay hindi masyadong malaki,
ang algorithm ay maaaring mabawi ang fraction, at iyon ang ginagawa natin dito.
At ngayon ay natitira tayong eksakto
parehong tanong tulad ng dati, na gaano karaming katumpakan ang kailangan natin?
At lumalabas na
eksakto ang parehong hangganan na mayroon tayo kanina ay gumagana sa kasong ito.
At kaya ang pagpili ng M nang eksakto
parehong paraan tulad ng dati ay gumagana rin dito.
Ngayon ito ay hindi necessarily
magbibigay sa atin ng R.
Ang matututunan natin kung gumagamit tayo ng
sapat na katumpakan, ay ang J over R, ngunit iyon ay magiging isang
fraction sa pinakamababang mga tuntunin.
Kaya maaari tayong maging malas sa kahulugan na ang random na pagpili ng J na ito ay maaaring magkaroon ng karaniwang kadahilanan sa R,
at itatago sila mula sa atin. Sa pinakamasamang kaso halimbawa, maaari tayong makakuha ng J equals zero at wala tayong matututunan.
Ngunit iyon ay literal na ang tanging
kaso kung saan walang matututunan.
Sa pangkalahatan, makakakuha tayo kahit man lang ng
isang hindi-trivial na kadahilanan ng R, at kung magagawa nating gumawa ng mga random na sample
at makakuha ng psi J para sa iba't ibang mga pagpili ng J, maaari nating talagang mabawi
ang R na may mataas na probabilidad sa pamamagitan ng pagkalkula ng pinakamaliit na karaniwang multiple
ng lahat ng mga denominator
na napansin natin. At hindi talaga ito nangangailangan ng maraming sample.
Ang buod ay na ang ilang mga pagpili ng J ay magtatago ng mga kadahilanan ng R, ngunit ang mga random na pagpili ng J
ay hindi makakatago ng
mga kadahilanan ng R nang matagal.
Kaya iyon ang ideya. Nananatili pa ring isaalang-alang ang pagpapatupad at partikular na malaman
kung magkano ang gastos.
Ang esensya ng ideya, upang kalkulahin ang order ng isang
ibinigay na elemento A at ZN star ay ang pag-apply ng phase estimation procedure
sa operasyong MA.
Alamin natin kung ano ang
gastos ng paggawa nito bilang isang function ng haba ng capital N, na ituturing ko ng maliit na n.
Narito ang isang circuit para sa phase estimation. Kakailanganin natin ang maliit na n qubit sa ibabang bahagi ng circuit
upang ma-encode ang mga elemento ng ZN sa binary. Kaya mayroon tayong N control qubit sa itaas at maliit na n qubit sa ibaba,
na maganda dahil tumutugma iyon sa mga pangalan na
ginamit natin kanina sa aralin.
Upang mabilang ang
bilang ng mga gate na kailangan natin para sa buong circuit, tumuon muna tayo sa gastos ng mga controlled unitary na operasyon.
Kung gagamitin natin ang mga pamamaraan
mula sa nakaraang aralin, aralin anim, maaari nating ipatupad ang MA gamit ang malaking O ng maliit na n squared na gate
gamit ang mahusay na klasikal na mga algorithm para sa aritmetika modular N.
Lalaktawan ko ang mga detalye sa video na ito, ngunit tulad ng ilang ibang bagay na tinalakay ko, maaari kang magbasa ng higit pa tungkol dito sa nakasulat na materyal para sa aralin.
Hindi sapat gayunpaman
ang ipatupad lamang ang MA.
Kailangan din nating ipatupad ang MA squared, MA sa ikaapat na kapangyarihan, sa ikawalong kapangyarihan, at iba pa
lahat ng paraan hanggang sa MA sa isang kapangyarihan na exponential sa M.
At alam natin na kailangan nating kunin ang M upang maging linear sa maliit na n
upang makakuha ng sapat na katumpakan.
Ito ay isang malaking alalahanin,
at binanggit ko ito kanina.
Kung ipatupad natin ang mga kapangyarihan
ng MA sa pamamagitan ng simpleng pag-ulit ng MA, maaari tayong mahulog sa problema dahil ang lahat ng pag-ulit ng MA
ay magkakaroon ng exponential na gastos.
Sa kabutihang palad, maaari tayong maglaro ng isang trick upang maiwasan ang pagtaas na ito sa gastos.
Ang maaari nating gawin ay ang mga sumusunod, para sa bawat kapangyarihang K na kailangan natin.
Una, kinakalkula natin ang A sa
kapangyarihang K, modular N.
Ito ang modular exponentiation problem na nabanggit ko sa aralin anim.
At maaari itong malutas nang mahusay. At ito ay isang bagay na maaari nating gawin gamit ang isang klasikal na computer.
Hindi kailangang isagawa ng quantum circuit ang kalkulasyong ito.
Kaya hayaan nating ang B ang maging resulta.
Kaya ang B ay isang elemento ng ZN star.
At pangalawa, sa halip na MA sa kapangyarihang K, gumagamit na lang tayo ng isang circuit para sa MB.
At iyon na iyon. Ang B ay isang elemento lamang ng ZN star, kaya ang gastos sa pagpapatupad ng MB
ay malaking O ng maliit na n squared.
Sa madaling salita, ang ginagawa natin ay nag-e-exponentiate sa ZN kaysa sa nag-e-exponentiate
ng isang quantum circuit.
Ngunit ang aktwal na operasyon na
nakukuha natin ay pareho sa alinmang paraan. Ito ay pagpaparami lamang ng A, K na beses.
Ito ay isang uri ng himala sa katunayan. At hindi natin magagawang
malutas ang order finding problem o ang pag-factor ng mga integer nang mahusay
gamit ang isang quantum computer
kung wala ito.
At ngayon na alam na natin na ang bawat isa sa mga controlled
unitary na operasyon, kabilang ang mga kapangyarihan, ay maaaring ipatupad
sa gastos na malaking O ng n squared, maaari na nating bilangin ang kabuuang
bilang ng mga gate na kailangan natin.
Mayroon tayong N Hadamard gate, at dahil ang M ay katumbas ng
malaking O ng maliit na n, ang gastos ay malaking O ng maliit na n.
Mayroon tayong M controlled unitary na operasyon na bawat isa ay may gastos na malaking O ng N squared.
Kaya ang kabuuang gastos dito
ay malaking O ng N cubed.
At sa wakas, ang quantum Fourier transform ay may gastos na malaking O ng n squared.
Kaya ang kabuuang gastos ay malaking O ng N cubed.
Partikular na, nakikita natin na kahit may ating
modular exponentiation trick, ang gastos ng mga controlled
unitary na operasyon ay nangunguna.
Ngunit gayunpaman, ang gastos
ay polynomial sa maliit na n.
Mayroon ding ilang klasikal na
mga kalkulasyon na kinakailangan, tulad ng pagkalkula ng mga modular exponentiation at pagpapatakbo ng continued
fraction algorithm,
ngunit ang mga kalkulasyong iyon
ay mayroon ding polynomial na gastos. At sa katunayan, maaari silang magawa sa malaking O ng N cubed na operasyon pati na rin.
May isang natitira pang isyu, at iyon ay kailangan nating makuha ang isa sa mga eigenvector na ito.
Paano natin ito magagawa?
Ang solusyon ay talagang napaka-simple. Hindi natin pinapatakbo ang circuit
sa isang eigenvector.
Pinapatakbo lang natin ito sa estado na isa, ibig sabihin ang binary
na encoding ng numero na isa, na iniisip natin
bilang isang elemento ng ZN.
Kaya gawin nating
palitan ito sa diagram.
Ang dahilan kung bakit ito gumagana ay dahil sa ekwasyong ito dito.
Ang estado na cat isa ay sa
katunayan isang uniform superposition ng R na eigenvector na
pinag-usapan natin.
At hindi iyon agad halata, ngunit kung kalkulahin mo ang
kabuuan, dapat mong makuha ang cat isa.
At kung pinapatakbo natin ang circuit sa estado na ito, ang output na makukuha natin
ay eksakto ang pareho tulad ng kung random tayong pumili ng J
at pinatakbo ang pamamaraan sa
eigenvector psi J.
Muli, hindi iyon halata, ngunit isang pagsusuri ang nagpapakita na totoo ito.
At sa wakas, iyon na iyon. Mayroon na tayong isang mahusay na quantum
algorithm para sa order finding.
May isang napaka-maikling bahagi pa
ng aralin na natitira at nauugnay ito sa relasyon sa pagitan ng integer factorization
at order finding.
Nabanggit ko na kung malulutas natin ang order finding problem nang mahusay, kung gayon maaari rin nating mag-factor
ng mga integer nang mahusay.
At gusto ko nang maikling ibigay sa iyo ang pangunahing ideya kung paano ito gumagana.
Ito ay ganap na klasikal. Ang bahaging ito ay talagang walang kinalaman sa quantum computing.
Narito ang isang paraan para mahanap
ng isang hindi-trivial na kadahilanan ng isang ibinigay na positibong integer N.
At sa pamamagitan ng paraan, gumagana lamang ang pamamaraang ito kapag ang N ay isang kakaibang numero, at hindi ito isang pangunahing
numero na itinataas sa isang kapangyarihan.
Ang dalawang kasong iyon kapag ang N
ay even o isang prime power ay maaaring hawakan nang hiwalay.
Mayroong mahusay na klasikal na pamamaraan para sa parehong pag-detect at
paghawak sa dalawang kasong iyon.
Ang pamamaraang ito ay probabilistiko. Maaari itong mabigo, ngunit ang
probabilidad ng kabiguan ay kadalasan ay kalahati,
at maaari nating simpleng patakbuhin ito
nang maraming beses nang nakapag-iisa upang bawasan ang probabilidad
ng error nang exponentially mabilis.
Una, pumipili tayo ng A sa pagitan ng
dalawa at N minus isa nang random, nang pantay-pantay.
Pagkatapos ay kinakalkula natin ang GCD ng A at N.
At kung ang GCD ay
mas malaki sa isa, kung gayon napakapalad natin.
Ang GCD ay magiging isang kadahilanan ng N at maaari nating i-output ito at itigil.
Kung hindi, ang algorithm ay nagpapatuloy at alam na natin ngayon na ang A ay nasa ZN star.
At ngayon kalkulahin natin ang order ng A, na dito kailangan natin ng isang quantum computer.
O marahil ay mayroon tayong iba pang paraan
upang kalkulahin ang order. Ang algorithm ay talagang hindi nagmamalasakit kung saan ito nanggaling, ngunit ang tanging paraan na alam natin
kung paano gawin ito nang mahusay
ay sa pamamagitan ng isang quantum computer.
Kung ang order ng R ay even, kung gayon kinakalkula natin ang GCD ng
A sa kapangyarihang R over dalawa minus isa sa N.
At kung ang GCD na iyon ay mas malaki sa isa, kung gayon muli mayroon tayong isang kadahilanan ng N, kaya i-output natin ito at itigil.
Kung hindi man ay nabigo ang algorithm. At sa kasong iyon, maaari tayong bumalik sa simula at pumili ng ibang A
at umasa sa mas magandang
kalalabasan sa susunod na pagkakataon.
At iyon na iyon. At sa pamamagitan ng paraan, kapag
nahanap na natin ang isang kadahilanan ng N, maaari tayong mag-recurse sa parehong kadahilanang iyon
at hatiin ito ng kadahilanang iyon hanggang makakuha tayo ng prime factorization ng N.
Kaya bakit dapat itong gumana?
Well, may dalawang pangunahing punto. Ang una ay na dahil ang A sa kapangyarihang R ay congruent sa isa modular N,
mayroon tayong na ang N ay naghahati ng A
sa kapangyarihang R minus isa.
Ang dalawang pahayag na iyon
ay talagang katumbas. Ito ang kahulugan ng mod N na mahahanap mo sa mga aklat ng number theory.
Pangalawa, kung ang R ay even, kung gayon ang ekwasyong ito na
mayroon tayo dito ay totoo.
Ito ang kilalang formula
para sa difference of squares.
Sa katunayan, ang ekwasyon ay totoo para sa lahat ng R, ngunit kailangan nating ang R over dalawa ay maging isang integer sa hakbang apat.
At kaya kung pinagsama natin ang dalawang katotohanan, makikita natin na ang bawat pangunahing kadahilanan ng N ay dapat na humahati sa isa sa dalawang
expression sa panaklong,
dahil iyon lang ang paraan
na mahahati ng N ang produkto.
Ngayon, maaaring mangyari na ang bawat
solong pangunahing kadahilanan ng N ay naghahati sa unang
expression sa panaklong at hindi sa pangalawa, ngunit para sa ating random na A,
iyon ay hindi gaanong malamang. At kaya kapag kinakalkula natin
ang GCD sa hakbang apat, malamang na makakuha tayo ng produkto
ng ilan sa mga pangunahing
kadahilanan ng N, ngunit hindi lahat.
Upang masuri ito nang maingat
ay nangangailangan ng ilang number theory, ngunit ito ay medyo pangunahing number theory.
Kaya kung nakakahanap ka ng number
theory na kawili-wili at gusto mong matuto ng higit pa, subukan mong pag-aralan ang pagsusuring ito.
Ang pag-aaral ng mga ganitong bagay ay isang mahusay na paraan upang matuto ng higit pa, ngunit iiwan ko iyon sa iyo.
At iyon ang katapusan ng aralin. Sa araling ito, tinakpan natin
ang phase estimation problem, kung paano natin malulutas ito nang mahusay
sa isang quantum computer,
at kung paano natin maaaring ilapat ang solusyon upang makakuha ng isang polynomial
na gastos na quantum algorithm para sa integer factorization.
Umaasa ako na sasama ka sa susunod na aralin, na tungkol sa Grover's
quantum searching algorithm.
Paalam hanggang sa muli.